here are the sexiest nationalities in
Asia damn there's actually a ranking
system so it's gonna be it's gonna be
Kazakh number one no it says number one
is Filipino
wow Anthony it's the best day of my life
predominantly mixed with most things
that's no that's not why you're saying
that the least Asian of the Asians
correct the variety is so diverse
because you got like a white guy looking
Filipino all the way to a Chinese guy
looking Filipinos which is why they can
easily take first place Pacquiao's
pretty cute number two it was lower than
a Filipino
I hate you guys
[Applause]
did you ever date a Vietnamese guy
before yeah why'd you say it so fast let
him finish the sentence dude no why not
you gotta pick either Japanese or
Koreans Japanese number two
I'll probably kill out there bro you
would
you would
everything